vous connais aussi pour votre scoop avec
françois hollande et julie gayet c'était
le 10 janvier 2014 souvient tous de
cette huile faut savoir que ce qui a mis
la puce à l'oreille à de nombreux
journalistes c'est une remarque de
stéphane guillon à l'époque alors qu'il
était invité au grand journal avec julie
gayet regardez c'est ça qui a mis la
puce à l'oreille
gelli vous avez soutenu la candidature
de françois hollande au moment de
l'élection présidentielle
pourquoi ça vous fait rire non non non
non moi je veux rien séville avait
commencé mais non c'est pas maintenant
commencer d'accord il venait sur le
tournage il est pas beau conte film est
donc voilà président aime le film de sa
femme beaucoup moins
[Applaudissements]
la chaleur il vous le savez avant on le
savait mais ça a été notre feu vert
c'est à dire que ces cinq dirigeants et
laurence pieau qui était la patronne de
l'océan moi j'étais devant ma télé elle
était devant sa télé et là je vois son
numéro s'afficher et elle m'a dit tu
seras tu as regardé la même chose que
moi je dis oui
elle me dit bon parce que ça faisait
quand même un an quand on travaillait
sur le sujet mais c'était super
compliqué parce qu'il ya des moments où
trouver l'endroit où il se voyait
et puis quand on est arrivé c'était déjà
trop tard de 15 jours et c'est donc il
ya des moments on abandonnait on passe à
autre chose et c'est mon avait toujours
ça en tête et jusqu'au jour où quelque
temps avant cette interview je trouve la
rue du cirque
donc là je me dis c'est dans le 8e c'est
là assez près de l'elysée je suis
entrain de m'imaginer ça un souterrain
je m'imagine plein de choses etc
puis je sais juste pour savoir les
téléspectateurs ta côté arts du cirque
c'est juste à côté donc sérieux vous
êtes dit peut-être console en il a fait
pour aller kane le gardien souterrain
dans un bâtiment à côté de l'hôtel
marigny qui est juste à côté c'est à
dire que quand il sortait de l'elysée il
passait par le souterrain jusqu'à
l'hôtel marigny s'ils sortaient en
scooter dans la rue du cirque il allait
jusqu'à cette porte là donc notre idée
de souterrain était pas était pas si
bête on a même été chercher le cadastre
pour voir s'il y avait un soutien voilà
ce qu'on comprenait pas on savait qu'ils
se voyaient mais nous on comprenait pas
comment il pouvait sortir on avait on
n'avait pas pensé à cette histoire de
casques et jusqu'au moment où ils un
jour j'ai vu sortir comme ça non mais
quand vous avez la photo là tout était
donc là vous voyez faso hollande
le bo françois hollande sur son scooter
à son scooter il arrive là ils enlèvent
le casse vous dit ça y est gelé vous
êtes où vous vous êtes vous être cachés
ou acer qu'on est plusieurs on a une
cage d'escalier qui est en face et donc
la cage d'escalier donne sur la rue on a
sous marin qui est dans un sous main
c'est un camion c'est quelque chose qui
aménage et là on l'avait déguisés comme
les
les véhicules du bristol c'est à dire
qu'on avait remarqué que la victime du
bristol s'étaient tous la même marque le
même modèle on avait les mêmes modèles
s'il y avait un panneau bristol on a
trop gras fier le panneau on l'a
plastifié on l'a mis devant et voilà on
était un d un des véhicules du de
l'hôtel
c'est parmi d'autres parce qu'il faut
savoir que sur un président il ya quand
même une sécurité à 6 avec lui il est
vraiment tout seul on secoue tabac et
ils n'étaient pas nombreux parce que
normalement on parle d'une dizaine ou
une quinzaine de personnes extérieures
il ya des précurseurs il ya il ya tout
un système
là on s'est vite rendu compte qu'il y
avait juste de mecs et qui faisait pas
du tout gaffe parce que en plus celui
qui conduit le scooter on n'a jamais
trop su que c'était mais il fait pas
partie du j'espère oui donc il y avait
peu vrai que c'est nicolas sarkozy
[Rires]
là la série de photos elle vaut combien
ça on veut savoir et non c'est
monstrueux disons que ça s'annonce et
c'est pas c'est pas les séries de photos
qui vendent le plus cher parce que en
plus là j'étais en commun entre
guillemets pour closer
donc c'est difficile de négocier le prix
et on va dire que c'est plusieurs de
dizaines de milliers d'euros et 200
mille euros c'est environ
ouais non non non c'est moi non c'est
vrai ouais 80 c'est un petit peu moins
bon mais bon c'est un énorme coup ça
c'est plus à un coup un coup encore eu
mais on a fait un gros coup et un coup
d'argent
moi j'ai une question à vous poser parce
que ça c'est une aile va là elle m'a je
me suis dit c'est quand même fou c'est à
dire que vous parliez de laurence pieau
quitté l'ancienne patronne de closer qui
est très sympathique d'ailleurs et on
lui on lui fait un bisou laurence quand
elle a ses photos françois hollande il
est président balle
est-ce qu'elle hésite un moment à les
publier et 6 arrière dire que ça a
besoin de faire fracasser c'est quand
même le président de la république et
est ce que françois hollande il a pas
moyen de faire pression
moi ce que je me suis venu ici c'est fou
quand même que le président il se
réveille comme nous le matin voilà est
qui mais attention une de closer
non mais ce qui le 6 le sabbat avant
alors non alors laurence pour prendre la
première question de laurence mais
direct et liva ya pas de problème à
partir du moment où un maître de
suggérer mène les photos c'est évident
qu'elles doivent sortir et puis la façon
si on fait ça c'est pour que ça sorte
après ils ont été françois hollande et
son équipe très amateurs parce qu'ils
avaient c'est fou normalement les
résidents ont des taupes à droite à
gauche sur les imprimeries ou la
personne personne n'a su ça a commencé
un petit peu a fuité et on n'a jamais
trop su comment mais quelques jours
avant et son conseiller en communication
a appelé toutes les rédactions il
n'avait pas ciblé spécialement closer
ils ont fait un forcing ils ont appelé
comme des malades tout le monde jusqu'au
dernier jour et laurence a été sympa
c'est qu'elle leur a fait porter à
l'elysée à minuit la veille
mais quand même le genre elle pour que
pour qu'ils voient ce qu'il ya dessus et
qui s'organise que c'est fou fraude est
content quand françois hollande il à
l'elysée à minuit on l'appelle lui il
est tranquillement en train de manger un
morceau bouffeurs de françois hollande
on le sait un pendant les cinq ans frère
il a fait que j'aime c'est démonter mon
frère lui les cas la cuisine de l'elysée
frère de loki ramé mois et dix mois il
reste de la boutargue en mémoire il ses
fins qui françois hollande est là il est
en plein de trucs on a un truc pour ou
le cruiser frères l'italie mais qu'est
ce qui dit à sa mère mais on oui ça va
faire en train de dormir à l'elysée est
tranquille mon père
elles en train de regarder balances ton
post rock intérim
je compose par la lumière
sébastien il a su que c'était bon et
j'en suis que c'était vous oui est-ce
que vous avez parlé vous avez un
contrôle fiscal après mais ça c'est une
broadway parce qu'on me l'avait jamais
fait ça de l'art est ce que je me suis
attaqué à d'autres présidents c'est le
premier il faut s'attaquer à nicolas
sarkozy aussi non parce que je vivais
aux états unis à l'époque au moment où
il a été élu mais j'ai travaillé sur
chirac j'ai travaillé donc son
mitterrand la ferme à marine foncé que
ça a un lien le contrôle fiscal juste
après ah bah oui mais non mais c'est
arrivé juste après la contrôleuse
maladie elle-même à la en plus y'a pas
grand chose à trouver chez vous mes
affaires je trouve pas ce que ça vient
de là haut c'est non ce soir une
émission de croix
c'est fou ce qu'on entend ce soit et ça
vous a rapporté beaucoup ont ce scoop
mais non d'un procès donc faut les
avocats le matin le contrôle fiscal etc
donc ça c'est ça vous rappelle juste aux
mères d'enfants ouais mais je regrette
pas c'est ben oui c'est des bons moments
ouais parce que il ya des rumeurs qui
disent ces conneries mais c'est vrai
qu'à un moment il y avait des gens qui
disaient c'est sarkozy c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui a donné le comment l'info
ouais c'est vrai on a dit ça oui ça va
non non ah non c'était quoi dans les
dîners comment ça se passe zhouqu était
book est très ami avec julie qu'aimez
vous le saviez ah oui savait bien avant
la paparazzade web et donc voilà une âme
il s'est alors approché n'a jamais rien
dit ouais c'est sur le plateau
effectivement avec de caunes que le plus
vraiment là ça mais ça on le savait on
le savait quand même deux hommes est
presque un petit peu comme ça mais pas
par le sacre approché je crois pas que
c'est venu de là si vous avez jamais
pensé que vous avez été instrumentalisée
et que ça l'arrangé bien finalement
alors à son instrumentalisation par qui
mais par françois hollande
non non parce que je sais que les délits
est donc je pense entre les avenues
peut-être que la presse je pensais qu'il
allait me ces dix jeunes en close alors
peut-être qu'une fille une fois que
c'était face à l'as bien arrangé non je
crois que ça l'est peut-être arrangé
mais bon bah on a dit que comme on a dit
que mitterrand était effectivement
content qu'on connaît si l'existence
réelle de sa fiabilité rang
alors c'est justement mazarine ouais la
fille de mitterrand aussi c'est vous oui
oui oui celle mitterrand s'est lui aussi
très intéressant castaldi c'est lui
mazarine un jour vous le révélait en 94
ans dans paris match
alors là c'est un tremblement de terre
là aussi vous avez des gros problème
avec ça eh bien pas du tout non non
franchement pas du tout et vous de toute
façon mitterrand a eu connaissance des
photos avant la parution parce qu'à
l'époque ça se faisait comme ça
maintenant c'est fini et donc paris
match très poli a été lui dire voilà on
a ça on voudrait le sortir et c'est
c'est dumas qui a fait l'intermédiaire
et qui a dit bon le président a dit
cette info orangé match a dit à nous
alors en j'enfonce ouais c'est
incroyable il ya johnny hallyday aussi
vous avez beaucoup suivi il était dur
approchée du navire est pas tant que ça
maintenant qu'ils sont plutôt les
sainsois est tellement habitué que
impassible à tranquille quoi ouais ouais
ouais mais le tour n'est pas là on est
ce que vous avez ce que vous avez déjà
flipper il ya un mec qui vous a qui a
voulu vous tapez ou un truc comme ça
j'ai eu johnny depp qui m'a couru après
qu'un couteau gibson qui m'a jeté des
cailloux sur la voiture en fait chaque
mail john draine aussi il ya des gens on
sait que faut faire attention et à
comment ça se passe avec emmanuel macron
l'actuel président ça se passe bien ça
va bien bah oui je les avais utile et
vous avez été l'aborder paris oui
j'étais l'aborder dans une rue quand il
était encore ministre
voilà on s'interrogeait ce jeune
ministre est avec son ancien professeur
donc c'était une histoire à nous qui
nous intéressait fortement
donc on s'y est mis un jour je les ai
retrouvés j'ai eu l'information ils
disent était il était du côté de mon
arbre j'y suis allé j'ai fait des photos
pendant une heure une heure et demie en
espérant qu'ils me voient pour
déclencher une réaction non pas vu donc
j'ai fini par y voir le garde du corps
je vais les écouter ce fait une heure et
demie je suis là regardez toutes les
photos que j'ai berges sont là ils vont
approcher de la place du tertre à cause
de moi ils vont être repéré donc ce
serait bien que il manque une photo
c'est en main dans la main deux faces
souriant et le mec est un peu abasourdi
il me reconnaît enfin il s'est animée
en plus c'est hollande machin donc il
est allé les voir donc là brigitte et
emmanuel mâcon me font signe
et puis j'arrive tellement
tranquillement en rigolant en disant bon
ben voilà on regarde et vous pouvez
machin est tous unis basse et wau
holland lâche un atout elle dit oui bah
on rigole un peu épineux débat vas-y
fais la photo et après il s'est rendu
compte que quelque part cette photo elle
était sortie elle était pas mal c'était
mieux qu'une photo qui aurait été faite
voilà on s'est revus donc j'ai fait
toute la campagne avec eux et la
première année disons de son mandat
c'est incroyable fou a alors cessé c'est
qu'il a la star la moins sympa bon j'ai
pas cité de français pour éviter des
problèmes bien français américains et
aux commandes gentils américains belges
et des sites est un peu fort ah oui
harrison oui parce que les audi la sadur
sont plutôt violent way harrison ford
il passe à riez pas content à chaque
fois mais bon et on n'est pas là ça se
voit non mais des paparazzi généralement
on n'est pas très contents de moi oui
mais il faut savoir que les stars
américaines à los angeles il ne se passe
pas une seule journée où ils peuvent
sortir sans gens croisés un d'accord
donc c'est quand même une habitude les
les stars françaises c'est quand même
plus rares et souvent ils les voient pas
à los angeles on garde nos distances
mais on est quand même là on est présent
on cherche souvent la réaction ouais
donc d'ailleurs dans de grandes dents
c'est ce que je montre dans le livre
c'est que je voulais montrer des des
photos qui étaient un peu différentes de
ce qu'on connaît des photos de paparazzi
et ça et elle m'a dit il ya rgo beaucoup
de célébrités avec qui j'ai sympathisé
parce qu'en étant français j'avais une
méthode de travail qui était d'être un
petit peu loin d'être respectueux et
d'être poli les américains qui sont
quasiment les mecs qui sortent de prison
qui sont des mecs de gang et ou qui leur
saute dessus qui les menace presque prêt
donc voila moi j'étais très vite leurs
potes quoi alors c'est qui le mot sympa
en france
c'est un animateur un chanteur un acteur
bon disons que j'ai eu une fois il ya
une altercation avec un ancien tennisman
chanteur qui était qui a dit quoi
voilà c'était peut-être sur le moment
amer revient aussi avec omar sy qui est
pourtant très sympathique tout le temps
un amour sa salle et ça dépend des
moments
d'accord voilà étaient visibles non mais
de temps en temps peut se faire qu il
était dans ce qu'il était dans son lit
tout simplement non mais tout en tant
que ce faire bien sûr ce qui est déjà
belle c'est vrai que les américains
avaient été très agacé par le fait que
vous avez fait les poubelles des stars
et comme ça on a su tout ce qu'elle
consommait à tous alors oui alors c'est
pas moi le premier qui ait fait ça mais
effectivement c'est dans les poubelles
des stars pour cela on a on a on est la
première poubelle pendant plus d'un an
j'ai mes pieds de tout mais on prend les
poubelles pendant plusieurs jours on
ressort les choses les plus marrantes
ouais on les écoute on fait les photos
et ça ça parle ça raconte quelque chose
sur ce ressort la célébrité c'est chez
paris hilton y avait plein de lunettes
gucci chanel on voit que s'en fout
cacher j'ai tout d'accord voilà mais il
peint il ya justin bieber aussi qui avez
perdu votre sang froid
vous aviez vous avez un petit zizi oui
c'est fou ça va énerver ouais merci
sébastien
[Applaudissements]